she was one of the gang of four who
attempted to break the mould of british
politics
with roy jenkins david owen and bill
rogers shirley williams formed the
breakaway sdp
in 1981 after splitting from the labour
party that was drifting to the left
in a political career spanning almost
six decades
she was one of the uk's most popular
politicians
and once tipped as the country's first
woman prime minister
shirley's courage against a lot of the
political oppositions
she faced um shone through and for a
woman
uh she was especially a trailblazer
you know she was without doubt one of
the greatest female politicians this
country's ever seen
she was a labour cabinet minister under
harold wilson and james callahan
but after losing her common seat in 1979
she stormed back into parliament in 1981
with a stunning by-election victory in
crosby on merseyside
there is no doubt that she should have
been the leader of the stp
she would have been far better than roy
jenkins and far better than me
i actually was supporting her i wanted
her to stand
when the sdp failed to achieve a
breakthrough
she backed a merger with the liberal
party and later became the liberal
democrats leader in the house of lords
and the darling of party activists
she retired from the lord's in 2016
and two years ago she reflected on her
career in a sky news interview
the most important single thing is to
actually
address the divisions between parties
and within
parties that have made the achievement
of greater equality
greater fairness greater justice almost
impossible
and to me that i find that heartbreaking
baroness williams has been described as
a trailblazer
and pioneer but ultimately the sdp
failed to break the mold john craig sky
news